>> Mark: LUKA JUST GOT A
TECHNICAL.
HE'S BEEN EJECTED WITH 31
SECONDS TO GO.
AND LUKA JUST GOT HIS 15th
TECHNICAL OF THE YEAR.
TWO TONIGHT.
HE'LL BE SUSPENDED FOR A GAME IF
HE GETS ONE MORE TECHNICAL.
IN THE REMAINDER OF THE REGULAR
SEASON.
EXCEPT FOR THE LAST GAME OF THE
REGULAR SEASON.
UNLESS SOME OF THESE TECHNICALS
GET RESCINDED.
WHICH COULD HAPPEN.
HE HAD ONE RESCINDED THIS YEAR
FOR WHAT HAPPENED UP IN NEW YORK
WHEN HE YELLED "AND ONE."
MOMENTS LIKE THIS ARE
FRUSTRATION WHEN YOU LOSE TO A
TEAM AGAIN.
THAT YOU FEEL YOU SHOULD NOT
HAVE LOST TO.
COUPLE OF FREE THROWS FOR THE
TECHNICALS.
ONE ON RICK, ONE ON LUKA.
LUKA'S WALKING OVER TO THE
TABLE.
HIELD GOES 1 OF 2 AT THE LINE ON
THE TWO TECHNICAL FOUL FREE
THROWS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED
THERE.
AND GIVEN THE STAKES AND GIVEN
WHAT HAPPENS BASED ON NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL FOULS, THAT ONE'S
GOING TO BE ONE THAT I'M SURE IS
GOING TO BE ARGUED BY THE MAVS
AND A TECHNICAL